Happen. The Joe Rogan experience that they
have some sort of special couch. Okay,
dog, my friend's girlfriend, we're all
sitting around. My friend's girlfriend,
so hot, so hot is one of those. Go with
Zach. We're sitting there and she goes,
and I was,
I was meditating and I saw a deer and it
looked at me and the deer gave me love
and we're all like, I'm just looking
at her tits. I was a young gun, Lazy.
She's so hot. She, she, she's so,
she's such an estrogen, you know.
And um, my buddy, of course, you know,
you had those swords and can't let it go.
Just let it go. Let her have
her thing. My buddy goes,
what gave you love?
Explain that shit to me.
Explaining why I get all
biological. Well, you know what?
You're close minded and
you're not intuitive.
I'm really intuitive and it became
massive, intuitive. My favorite thing,
I love that shit.
But those people that claim that they
have some special connection with animals,
like animals just recognize who I
am. They know my nature. You know,
kind of schooled me,
Megan Fox.
I was doing a movie with her and,
and I assumed she started talking about
signs and I was making fun of like
psychics and signs and all,
and Megan goes, well, um,
maybe you ever think that maybe you're
a little close minded. And I go, no,
not scientific minded and no I'm not.
And I think all psychics are liars
and I think astrology is bullshit.
But then like Megan literally went into
her knowledge of science and geology and
everything else and I was like,
oh, you're a fucking, oh wait,
you're a really hot intellectual
and you know a shit load.
And I made a judgment on you. It was very,
it was actually embarrassing isn't it?
And interestingly, you would automatically
make a judgment on someone who's hot,
like Ah, utilize been easy as fuck.
Right. And she's not like that.
Like a judgment that you would
make on the son of a rich man.
Like if someone correct grew up in,
is in the family business and his
father was a, a very successful man,
but he's taking over the family business,
you would assume this guy's a bitch.
Yup. Right? Yup. Most of the time. Most
of the time you're wrong. So often. Yes.
It's such a bad debt. Yeah. Cause like if
a great, if a great man has a son, yeah.
Most like he's going to teach that Sun's
cool shit and the sun's going to have
to like live up to a certain standard.
Right. Well that was the thing with Megan.
I would notice after I had
that interaction with her,
I've known her a little bit cause I know
her husband really well. And then, uh,
and then I noticed that every
time we wouldn't be shooting,
she'd be reading a book of substance.
Like that's what she does when she's
not on set. So I was like, well,
what are you doing? You're, you're,
you're laying an iPhone next to your head.
What am I doing?
Their iPhone next to the other side
of your head and you have these weird
conversations with that.
That's my favorite thing you did.
I got to start doing that again.